what was the most toughest like boxing
movie had to do yeah I would say just
the whole thing does the whole thing no
one specific move that came to mind do
you know how many moves we did in this
movie do you only think of one
[Applause]
don't let him destroy everything you've
built
here I come
now congratulations on the film I'm
Michael B Jordan Michael B directing and
Michael B beefing with Jonathan Majors
out
of all the movies
out of all the movies to be a
directorial debut why create three I
felt like it was like you know it was
the perfect timing you know I knew the
character so well I knew the world I
kind of had a a pretty I good idea of
what Adonis would be going through at
this stage of his life personally and
professionally and I felt like you know
there was nobody else to really tell
that story you know than myself so and I
was ready for a challenge you know I
wanted to you know I wanted to evolve I
wanted to grow so I just kind of jumped
off the deep end and you know
see what happens talking about like his
current phase of life um the friendship
between Adonis and Damian is one of the
central themes of this film how did you
know that Jonathan is the Damian like
the antagonist giordanis oh how did I
know I mean I found out I think I knew
he was a phenomenal actor that would be
able to like hit the emotional notes
that I needed to hit for for Damien to
be the best antagonist for Adonis you
know Adonis is very complex he's very
layered
um so that you need an equally as
complex and layered uh antagonists and
Damien so just seeing some of his old
work and understanding what I could do
if he just trusted me in the process and
it worked out now Jonathan a few weeks
ago told me that you're currently his
best friend Michael B Jordan is my cut
man and and probably currently my best
friend is he yours or is there someone
else in the role like I won't tell him
no I mean he's definitely one of my best
friends man it's like he I got a brother
now and and the way you know we've kind
of connected over the past couple years
is something special so yeah man he's
right there in the mix with my with my
other best friends like he's a part of
the crew now so like for sure now many
franchises end as a Trilogy Rocky
famously had six and Creed is currently
at its Thug do you think they're most
stories to tell and do you want to tell
them now and soon or maybe come back in
like 20 to 30 years as some franchise is
known to do I don't know that's a good
question you know I definitely I know I
want to expand the Creed verse there's
more stories definitely be told I don't
know when and where you know and how you
know just yet but you could definitely
expect more from the cree family you've
been here for like eight years like I
imagine
training has been intense and crazy and
crazy throughout the first films what
was the most toughest like boxing movie
had to do
I mean this this this fight this movie
was probably the toughest
one out of the three
um so
yeah I would say just the whole thing
does the whole thing no one specific
room that came to mind do you know how
many moves we did in this movie do you
ever think of one nah they're all tough
after a certain point they're also
foreign